he's Chris Sims pro football talk live
co-host former NFL quarterback and let
me start with the serious question where
do you rank do you think with your
family like who does your dad love the
most I think he loves my sister the most
by far yeah she's uh you know the girl
she's daddy's girl so I think you know
she's she's probably one I'm probably
third right now in my household I would
say that's probably second you know so I
don't know yeah I'm low on the totem
pole maybe with mom and dad's love with
me right at this point okay but what
does Matt do that wouldn't rank him
second above you who's now a big TV star
he's right he's around more he's living
in the same house more you know my dad
still is like you know I wish you saw
I'm doing my dad boys I wish you still
lived here in Franklin Lakes you know
you can bring the kids over and I'm like
what but dad I do a show at 7:00 a.m.
every morning do you want me to wake up
at what 4:30 four o'clock to get there
and do it so yeah I think it's maybe out
of sight out of mind that's hurt me a
little bit do you love your dad or your
mom more oh well that's not even close
mom I mean that's not even yeah I mean
mom come on dirty I call her dirty Diana
she's the best
I mean first off she was a great mom and
man she had a deal with my dad for all
these years and she's still a widow that
just tells you how good she is what was
it like though when your dad came home
your dad got beat up a lot he got
roughed up a lot of those years with the
Giants and did he bring games home uh
yes he did when they lost he you know
not that he was like you know mad or
yelling at us or like treating us with
disrespect but when dad lost you know a
game to the Philadelphia Eagles and
Reggie White and Randall Cunningham you
know there wasn't gonna be any
conversations in the car ride home back
you know from the stadium and then when
he got home he was gonna usually he
would pull up his chair he would have
this chair and he'd pull it up real
close to the TV and he put his feet up
and had the TV about six feet from him
and watch you know highlights and the
sunday night football game but
really say anything to the family the
whole night so that's usually how it
went Wow
oh yeah that's all I wanted to know
Chris thanks for joining us as always I
was wondering with these rookie
quarterbacks it's tough enough to get
acclimated in the NFL with the speed and
all the information if you're looking at
you trying to handicap this Joe burrow -
uh Justin Herbert who's gonna have the
easiest transition if you can even well
refer to it as he yeah right yeah it's
not easy you're right no me neither
or none of the situations are easy but I
do think when I look at it I go Joe
burrow and twoa have an advantage I
think over guys like Jordan love who's
very raw and was in a very simple
offense
Justin Herbert not a very complicated
offense and creativity there up in
Oregon
you know Joe burrow got coached by a guy
that's an NFL offensive coordinator and
Joe Brady who worked under Sean Payton
so I think he's gonna have a good feel
for how offenses are run in the NFL and
that's kind of the same logic I would
use with to add an you know yeah you
know that that Alabama offense you watch
it it's got everything and he's being
coached by Nick Saban tell you tells you
he's being coached like a pro so I think
those are the two guys I would favor in
that conversation more than the other
because of what they came from how are
they going to be Jo burrows first pass
could be his first pass you know there's
no preseason here right right I know
it's crazy
III know it's unbelievable and yeah I
mean I don't think you know Cincinnati's
trying to deny we know Joe burrow
starting game one week one play one know
the good thing for him is he played a
lot of football in the last two years
like we talked about he was in a
pro-style system he's been around and
played against a lot of pro players
that's the benefit of playing an SEC
football I mean pretty much every team
you play every week's got a few
professional defensive linemen a few
pros in the secondary and I think you
know he'll adjust fairly quickly because
I think he's very talented and smart
yeah it feels like that first pass is
gonna be a little drop-off pass to Joe
Mixon out of the backfield that's no
doubt I see your age
but the preseason we know it's necessary
for the rookies just to get kind of
acclimated to the stage and teammates
the bright lights the whole thing there
but if you're a veteran how much are
they gonna miss the preseason not a
whole lot they're not now I think the
other wrinkle you have to throw into
this conversation too is we'll see what
the rules are set up between the NFL and
the NFL PA how many padded practices
they're gonna be able to have and how
many times they'll be able to go full
contact you know that's gonna be a big
part of it
but it's something that bothers me it's
something that's not being talked about
right now you know is the kind of the
player safety issue I think you're gonna
have more players coming into training
camp out of shape than ever before you
know no matter how most of these guys
yeah you're working out at home but it's
still not like being there in the
facility competing against guys every
day that you're working out with the
coach is yelling at you doing all those
things so get back to your question it's
imperative for the rookies the second
year the third year guys all those guys
who just don't have a lot of snaps under
their belt you know those are big reps
and that's why you know I know the one
thing that my coach friends have told me
is they're disappointed or scared that
there's not going to be enough 11 on 11
contact type drills when training camp
does come around which a course is going
to hinder those type of guys abilities
to make the team and things like that
but also Cam Newton here is a veteran
but coming back from injuries and then
joining a new team and oh by the way
replacing Tom Brady yeah I know it's a
lot of moving parts there you're right
now the one thing is of the guy like Cam
Newton you know he knows he can play he
knows he belongs it's gonna be more
about you know him getting this this New
England system which is as complicated
as any in football and getting a grasp
of that and then I think the big thing
is to that you know and again New
England their brain surgeon says the way
they think and tactically attack things
which I'm sure building right now it's
thinking about you know how can I make
the most of a 80 man roster with all
these rules of koban 19 and do that I'm
sure he's surgically dissecting what he
wants to do but yeah then
part of that question - and what makes
New England so great is you know they'll
formulate the offense around Cam Newton
and the fact of oh he does this good all
right let's find 20 different ways to do
this and then oh he doesn't do that well
I will work on it and maybe we'll just
infuse it in the offense here and there
that's where they're really great and
yeah they're a little hamstrung by this
but they have these type of Cam Newton
place in their playbook I'll say that
Dad they definitely do you know this is
the most extensive playbook in football
it's just I think there's gonna be more
of a you know a primary uh instant you
know primary thought of their offense
this year as when yours fast it was
trickery he's Chris Sims Pro Football
Talk Live co-host with Mike Florio and
former NFL quarterback you start to look
at certain situations here dak Prescott
is in Kent we're gonna be in camp but
you know you gets a franchise tag and
then you don't get that long-term deal
and and how does that not affect you
where is everybody else got long-term
deals from Jerry Jones and you know the
Cowboys
I think messed this up because they
could have gotten him for what we would
look at as a bargain a year ago right
and and now you know they're gonna pay
top dollar and then he bet on himself
again this year so yeah how does this
end with the Cowboys in dak Prescott I
mean it's either gonna be the same story
and they're gonna be franchise tagging
him again next year and he's gonna roll
the dice on that which Hey rolling the
dice this era 2020 at the quarterback
position is not like 1992 anymore right
with all the rules to protect the
quarterbacks it's not a as a dicey
situation as it once might have been so
I can understand that Prescott saw
process but you know what I worry about
let's see just from the Dallas
standpoint is you know kind of the Joe
Klecko effect hey Dallas we know that
offense has Got Talent and what they
just got CD lamb and the top 20 picks of
the draft so what I would be scared
about him if I'm a cowboy thin or a
cowboy employee is he has a huge year
again statistically and then the winds
match it match it this year and then you
go oh man now we're gonna have to pay
him
probably you know Patrick mahomes mess
up this conversation - a little bit so
yeah Dallas messed up and not getting
out in front of this I agree with you
there totally I do think dak Prescott
was probably being a little aggressive
what I've been led to believe that what
he was asking for and then I think with
him a home signing for what he signed
over the next few years I think that
certainly probably put a little wrench
in that conversation - I don't know if
you saw this comment my Brandel Chamblee
on the Golf Channel
but he said Tiger is the most
underachieving golfer of all time
because of all the talent and that he he
only won you know what he's won so far
and that he should have won far more in
it and it made me wonder is aaron rogers
gonna be looked at it that way now his
resume is not the same as Tigers but you
know right realizing everybody says he's
the most talented quarterback he's ever
played right and if he if he only ends
up with one Super Bowl will he be the
least achieving or underachieving
quarterback well I I think yeah I think
he'll be viewed by many that way you
know he won't be viewed that way by me
yeah and I think you know people you
know you know then I know you're great
fan you got a great feel for the game
you know I would have a hard time
thinking you would think that way either
you're smart enough to realize that you
know he hasn't had the most creative
offenses around I'm a big time talent
and shut down defenses and he can't
catch on sidekicks against the Seahawks
or the Super Bowl and and play defense -
so there's no I think the front office
of the Packers under paved as much as
any front office in the last one I I
totally agree I totally agree and then
of course I think this year's you know
offseason was a debacle - dear where you
got a guy that's still playing at a very
high level but yeah I think widely
that's what he's gonna be criticized you
know Aaron Rodgers is one of those guys
that I look at a little like LeBron
James where he's gonna be a victim of
his own greatness to a degree because he
brought some teams in the NFC
championship like in 2016 against the
Falcons they had no business being there
but he's Aaron Rodgers he could just
carry his team there but then they got
overwhelmed by a team instead of like
Oh Oh this team's not that great so I'm
Aaron Rodgers and I can overcome it uh
so I in a lot of years of getting into
the playoffs where I go who the team was
really average I don't even know if they
were a playoff team and they got in so
all those things are gonna hurt him when
it all comes said and done but it won't
hurt him in my eyes you know that
yeah and Dan Marino went through this
for a long period of time that he went
to one Super Bowl never got back went to
I think one conference championship game
after that but we look at Dan Marino and
say did he underachieve as a whole I
mean it sounds strange to even say it I
know but you know where Brady
overachieved because he wasn't a
first-round pick and you know of course
his resume like John Elway almost
underachieve by losing three Super Bowls
and then he won two because of Terrell
Davis now we look at him and go yeah
he's he yeah he achieved Joe Montana
overachieved because he was a third
round draft pick right you know drew
Brees is he over achieved or under
achieved well yeah you know I think he's
I think he's over achieved really but
you know it's about the support system
you know that's where I look at it and
you know me this is one of my pet peeves
cuz we just all boil it down to wins and
losses and we put it on one guy and you
know as great as Joe Montana is right I
mean John Montana's great alright he
left the 49ers and all they did was go
to NFC championship games and Super
Bowls after he left you know so you look
at that and you go oh okay you know yeah
there was a team there there's a great
coaching staff there was a lot of things
around him he had an offensive system
that was ahead of its time and things
like that where yeah yeah I don't know
if Aaron Rodgers necessarily had the
benefit of the doubt there dan Marino
hard to name too many great defensive
players or running backs that were ever
around him let alone some of the other
coaches that came off of that staff
there's no greatness there either so
it's a pet peeve of mine it really does
bother me but I understand the
conversations and yeah that's why I try
to get the Super Bowl rings conversation
I always try to you know make people
think about it a little bit more and but
it's like Russell Wilson is a
hall-of-famer he's over achieved in
people's eyes because he was not a high
draft pick here dak
Oh has overachieved in someone right
right right Matthew Stafford
underachieved Matt Ryan's gonna be a
hall-of-famer but we might look at it
and say he under like it's where you're
drafted how much you're getting paid
that we start there and go are you
overachieving or underachieving and you
cease yes with your draft selection
you're right it's big part of the
conversation which is not fair either
you know it's not you know I mean you
know again sometimes you miss evaluate
guys or you know Tom Brady you know he
was allowed to lift the weight and work
on his 40 time before he went to the
combine you know maybe he would've been
a sixth-round pick him he didn't have
that picture he has no muscle and he ran
a 5 to 40 so you know he could get some
of that blame too but you know listen
it's a great conversation it certainly
is way to find Ronny what do you think
Brady runs at 40 no probably I think
he's probably faster now than he was
then which is really really not I I do
because I think he actually works on it
now I don't I think it was a period in
his career where he just said I'm a
great thrower and I can shuffle in the
pocket and I don't give a damn about
anything else and I heard him make some
comments a few years ago where he was
like all right I want to start sprinting
and doing those things because if it is
third and three and they played coverage
and double-team everybody he wanted to
be able to run for four yards I think
he's got more running yards towards the
end of his career than he does early on
but like it's not he's not breaking five
flat Dan I don't think he's breaking
five flat right now that's that that
would be my guess can he beat
Roethlisberger ooh I don't think he can
I don't think he can it be a close one
now Big Ben I don't sure he's run a
sprint you know since he came out for
the combine so they're going in
different directions that way but you
know you know yeah it because that I
think I'd give the nudge to
Roethlisberger I'm trying to think whose
the slowest quarterback starting
quarterback because we know who the
fastest quarterback is especially
there's it's Philip Rivers the slowest
quarterback mmm I know I'm sitting here
looking at teams right now and I think
he could be in that conversation with
Brady certainly and I'm trying to look
if there's just anybody else I think you
might have nailed it though I think it
might be
those two guys really I don't see
anybody else that jumps out to me in
that fashion so I think hey I would pay
to see those guys race oh I would too I
hear you I mean yes I mean but but again
it shows you it's not about that always
you know Brady's one of the best pocket
manipulators we've ever seen in the
sport you know as far as moving around
always staying in throwing position and
having that sixth sense of what's around
him so you know again you don't have to
be fast if you could have quick feet and
great body control and understand a few
techniques of throwing the football you
can be really dangerous just like Dan
Marino I mean Dan Marino I don't think
he could have beat me you know in a race
if I ran backwards in my prime
but Dan he can move those feet and fire
that ball it's great to talk to you
Chris
hope your status with your dad improves
a little bit we'll see we'll see what I
can do I don't know I hope I'm still in
the trust and get some money when he's
done who gets the Superbowl ring Oh
hopefully I just want Super Bowl 21
hopefully I should get it I was you know
my brother wasn't alive yet so he
shouldn't qualify for that my sister was
only 2 I was the only one there at the
game I should get that for sure thank
you Chris see ya that's Chris Sims Pro
Football Talk live co-host